philip rivers
no longer playing for the chargers will
be a free agent march 18. can sign with
anyone and i do a couple of spots every
week on the score in chicago and one of
the first things they asked me yesterday
morning philip rivers to the bears
they're looking for a mitchell trubisky
replacement
your thoughts big cat on the possibility
of an upgrade in the form of phillip
rivers over mitchell trubisky for 2020.
okay so
i don't know if this is
all the way
an upgrade and i like phil rivers but we
watched phil rivers last year and i
you know mitch trubisky was not good
last year that's not what i'm saying
but this is a precarious situation the
bears are in a weird spot because they
have to say that they're all in on mitch
trubisky they have to say he's the
starting quarterback next year i know
they're going to want to bring in some
kind of competition
but you can't bring in a guy who will
demand to be the starting quarterback
and then completely flush down mitch
trubisky i mean obviously you can but
don't you think that the bears are in a
spot where they box themselves in
with just where they picked mitchell
biski what they've said about them the
fact they went to the playoffs you know
two years ago that they can't bring in a
guy who's gonna demand to be the
starting quarterback and i don't see
philip rivers going anywhere where he is
not the guaranteed starting quarterback
yeah i mean i agree with you when you
still have the same general manager who
made the trade from three to two to get
mitchell trubisky and not pat mahomes or
deshawn watson you've got to continue to
ride with this guy you can't put him on
the bench you have to hope that that
it'll turn around and it'll be more like
2018 than it was in 2019 so i agree with
you it becomes a tough sell for ryan
pace now for matt and aggie he may think
hey i just want to win football games
and i get a savvy veteran like philip
rivers who will understand my offense i
what is he not a savvy veteran no this
graphic
oh oh oh yes the 2017 draft first round
quarterbacks trubisky mahomes watson
pick number two true biscuit but hey the
49ers could have had mahomes as well
they passed on him does that help
probably not but uh look here's the
thing with trubisky they do have to give
him i think one more year and you can't
just rip the ball out of his hands and
make philip river the starter and you
touched on the point that peter king and
i discussed yesterday i don't know that
there's a team out there that says to
philip rivers you're the guy without
question we're not going to draft
anybody who may supplant you in november
you don't have to compete with anybody
you're the quarterback barring injury or
some other complete and total disaster
week one through week 17 and the
contract proves it 27 million 28 million
something like that that makes it clear
you're the guy i don't know that there's
a team that's going to do it maybe
carolina if they do trade cam newton
maybe the titans if they would lose ryan
tannehill although i don't think they're
going to
maybe tampa bay if they decide to move
on from the jameis winston experience
but i take winston over philip rivers
big cat uh i i just don't know if
there's gonna be a team that clearly and
unequivocally makes philip rivers their
guy and i especially don't think it'll
be the bears yeah i'm trying to think
i'm going through like the progressions
in my head saying who who would be that
team
and i don't really see it but you know
what you know what i'll throw out one
team that's going to be interesting what
they do
uh this offseason how about the
indianapolis colts are they totally sold
on jacoby brissette or do they bring in
someone else and say hey we're going to
give a shot you know you guys got to
compete for the job
well they've got bersette signed for at
least one more year i'm pulling up his
contract now he is signed through 2020
six million dollar salary 8.875 million
dollar roster bonus uh they've also got
brian hoyer under contract as well but i
think phillip rivers possibly but
possibly an upgrade there what about new
england if if tom brady leaves right
it's good and i think i think listen i
think philip rivers best play may be to
just wait because we assume this game of
musical chairs is going to result in
quarterbacks being left over looking
around saying where's my job there's a
chance there's going to be teams when
the dust settles saying where the hell's
my quarterback and that may be when
philip river swoops in and finds that
spot where he's the week one through
week 17 starter it is going to be
fascinating because the quarterback
carousel we haven't seen anything like
this particular year with tom brady drew
brees jameis winston dak prescott
possibly
phil rivers joe burrow and tua coming
into the league it's gonna be awesome
i'm looking at jacoby bessette's
contract he's got seven million that
becomes fully guaranteed
on march
22.
um
they paid him 20 million guaranteed
already they could escape the contract
though if they decide to move on from or
they could just keep him it's not that
expensive keep him and get phillip
rivers that could happen we'll be right
back
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports